raise your hand if you hit snooze this
morning don't be embarrassed put your
hands up now raise your hand if you
didn't keep your hands up did you think
about which hand you were going to raise
my guess is you didn't we make quick
unconscious decisions every single day
in fact we make about 35,000 decisions
each day I want to figure out for me
which one of those are conscious so I
decided to journal my decisions for just
one day I came to 63 conscious decisions
which leaves about 550 five times as
many to the unconscious when I'm at it
what I'm going to ask you here today is
to start thinking about which decisions
you move into the unconscious and
potentially move some of those into the
conscious into mindful decision-making
mindful decisions have massive impact
now I'm not saying to make every single
one of your decisions in a conscious way
if the exhausting in fact we all get
exhausted with decision overload by the
end of the day so it only makes sense
that we push a lot of our decisions into
the subconscious where I got in trouble
is when I move one too many decisions
into the subconscious it took a really
simple question for my best friend Lucy
to get me out of autopilot and back in
control of my life to live a happier
more impactful length this was back in
March 2010 I'm Lucy and I were running a
5k together it's about halfway through
the race and I was telling Lucy about my
job now is still four months away from
finishing my time and investment baking
but I was telling Lucy about this
amazing new job I'd lineup where I'm
like in investment banking or I was
getting about four hours of sleep a
night constantly canceling on family and
friends and stressed to a point of panic
on a daily basis no this new job would
be so much better the hours would only
be eight to eight
on average and I wouldn't have to work
every weekend just every other weekend
or so and the pain was great and then
Lucy asked the question that changed my
life will you enjoy it now have you ever
been asked that question just stops you
in your tracks I think I'd laughed and
said something like no it's gonna be
more of the same and I literally stopped
mid race I had been living on track a
track that my co-workers in the year
above me had set up for me they had done
two years of investment baking just like
i was doing and then they went on to do
private equity my next job and then the
envisioned business school this amazing
place we finally get to decide what
makes you happy and go do it I had been
living on this track I never gave it any
conscious thought in fact I actually
hated vinings but my next job in finance
was just the next step so I was going to
go do it my best friend Lucy changed my
life with a really simple question she
got me to question my assumptions and
start thinking about what I wanted to do
with my life what track I wanted to be
on what my vision was and more
importantly she gave me permission the
permission to be the active decision
maker in my life I actually went ahead
and quit the job in private equity I had
lined up for those of you who have never
could a job that you haven't started yet
it's very hungry would you recommend it
and instead I just decide take time off
and figure out what finally makes me
happy it was quite simple time with
family and friends and new adventures
and when I struck the right balance only
then could I truly be impactful to those
around me my best friend Lucy changed my
life with a really simple question she
forced me to be the active decision
maker in my own life to choose to make
choices
when I was the active decision maker
when I was in control then I was happy
and then I can make an impactful
contribution in my relationships in my
work and my impact in the world when i
took this mindful time off it was
amazing i got to wake up every single
morning and decide what I wanted to do
it started with this decision to quit my
job but catapulted me into making all of
my decisions in this mindful way I first
decided to make a list of all the things
I want to do and try just because I want
to be so purposeful unconscious in this
time off it was things like taking my
running we're really out of breath 5k
all the way to a full marathon or
spending time with family and friends
and not falling asleep at birthdays and
other events or giving back to my
community by volunteering the circle of
friends the nonprofit I've been active
with in high school and it was amazing
every single day I decided what I wanted
to be doing with my life I was up for
going on a friday in the morning to a
music vessel with my friend Cammy or
grabbing beer is just about every single
Tuesday with good friends from high
school and when I returned to work I
stayed true to my vision I decided to do
a job in corporate strategy where I was
still learning and being stretched but
my hours are still nine to five every
single day I was challenged and learning
but I can still make it home in time for
dinner with my parents on a Friday night
and I say true to my vision even today I
make sure to mindful eat ache time to
nurture my relationships back home and
I've decided to do a career in cpg
marketing which I'm excited about but
it's still going to be a lot of learning
for me my best friend Lucy changed my
life of a simple question she got me to
think about what I wanted to be doing
with my life so I could be happy and so
I could actually make an impact on
those around me now the things i talked
about they're all true to my vision have
your decisions in the past week or even
the past year been consistent with your
vision if not how will you mindful e
make decisions going forward for me it's
talking it through with my friend
including Lucy it helps me create a lot
of space to question my assumptions what
works for you is a journaling meditation
going for walk or run be happy be
impactful mindful decisions have massive
impact